finally crime is Raging unchecked
through our cities as you know forcing
companies to take unprecedented steps to
protect their customers and their own
workers Starbucks for example now
providing barristers with active shooter
training as murders rapes robbery surge
Nationwide the dramatic step by
Starbucks comes after the coffee giant
Force to close 16 of their stores over
safety concerns and 7-Eleven now urging
all Los Angeles locations to shut down
at night to allow police to investigate
a string of deadly robberies meanwhile
Crime Victims are being tossed to the
curb in La as hyper liberal D.A George
gascon disbands the unit that notifies
Crime Victims about parole hearings that
might be releasing their attackers
gascon defending his decision to kill
the hearings saying quote well a victim
has a right to be notified they also
have a right not to be contacted say
what what does that mean judge means
he's a fool it means that he is he is to
save a couple of dollars he is taking
away a sacred right of Crime Victims you
attribute to him a good motivation it's
not about saving money it's about
endangering victims and benefiting the
criminal this lifer unit as they call it
in uh California I mean every D.A has it
what you do is you prosecute people they
go to state prison if they're if they're
up for parole what you do is a
prosecutor and I would send my
prosecutors out they'd go to Albany in
New York and then they would argue
before the parole board as to whether or
not that that person needs to come out
we would often call the family members
who were traumatized by this if the
victim is deceased and we end up calling
other people so that the parole board
knows that there are people still afraid
Now understand this nonsense they have a
right not to be notified he's full of it
the law requires him and that's why they
have a right to be notified you know why
we have that law because when these
dirtbags get out of prison they come
after the family members they come after
the people who've testified against them
they come after the families that were
in court every day on behalf of the
victim and those victims families are in
danger and order of protection is
nothing but a piece of paper it's not
going to save them so the least thing
that we can do is to give them notice
that this person is coming out this man
is in he is he is incapable of running a
DA's office in fact he shouldn't be
allowed in the DA's office well we'll
see what happens with the recall there
Katie uh you have Starbucks it's so
ironic the epitome of lightness and
sweetness and and modernity and now
they're teaching uh you know uh shooter
training I mean how I bitterly ironic is
that well the fact that they're having
to close all these stores in these
cities just proves that the criminals
are running the show when you have to
start leaving a number of locations
because it's unsafe for your workers to
be there and who suffers the most right
it's the people who are trying to make
an honest living by going to work at
Starbucks by going to work at these
other stores we've seen across the
country leaving town and when one part
of the system which in the LA case or in
the DC case and as we saw in San
Francisco we're seeing in Philadelphia
if one part of the system is broken I
mean the D.A is not Prosecuting the
cop's job then is basically just to run
cleanup because the criminals are are
running free I remember being in Times
Square six months ago in the the
convenience store and the Walgreens and
these guys just came in and put stuff
under their their jackets and walked out
and we walked out our police there and
but the workers can't put themselves
into a dangerous position by trying to
stop them they don't know if they're
armed they don't have the liability and
that's the other thing is companies are
are under the hook for too is that if
someone gets hurt or killed in their
store they may be liable for it given
there's no deterrence uh in these
neighborhoods to the criminals who are
absolutely in control you know Greg here
it reminds me of the Freddie gray riots
in Baltimore what happened they closed
the big Rite Aid the only one that
service that neighborhood on the west
side of Baltimore it seems to me the
these 7-Elevens closing in all the inner
cities what's happening is that the
residents of the community are being
denied and deprived a vital service what
if they need a quarter milk at 11
o'clock at night or whatever that's the
that's always been the issue with a lot
of these uh uh I would say Elites like
gascon and others is that they don't go
to 7-Eleven and they have their
employees handle the Starbucks run so
they don't this is not something that
directly affects them and until it does
directly affect them they continue this
way I'm going to defend and gascon
though um you know he has got a tough
job he's let out so many Thugs and
scumbags consider the phone bill having
to call all their victims I mean that
could take days to do that but that's
what's happening I know that's my joke
but I can safely bet that most of the
victims are women so this is another
case of where the feminist groups why
aren't they speaking up and then his
excuse he said that the parole
notification he used the word triggering
which again is ironic but this is
another case where they are so obsessed
with these BS woke jargon words instead
of authentic action as if this is like
you know I'm really worried that
somebody me calling you might hurt your
feelings yeah but he's going to come and
kill me right so it's like it's like
you're replacing a real concern with a
fake concern and you're telling them you
can't handle the truth we're not going
to tell you this is it's crazy this is a
dystopian nightmare he's lying oh go
ahead it's okay I
you know in terms of Starbucks can you
imagine what shooter training would look
like well how would you feel if there
was a Starbucks barista and he's packing
themselves or just teaching them to run
away they're too Duck and Cover behind
the espresso
that's what you need
to relax Times at Ridgemont High
remember he stopped the robbery coffee
to the fish yes or to somewhere else
yeah oh meaning Geraldo of all people
you know exactly what I mean so they
don't put Starbucks where the gang
activity is they usually put it in
commercial districts where there's nice
foot traffic where these yuppies can go
and plug in their
laptops and text and zoom mom and ask
Dad for money and where people just
waste their days and kick up their feet
and do what they do it's like people
spend all day there if you're talking
about their bathrooms and now their
bathroom policy just got buckled because
they opened it up to everybody because
they got a bad headline and people
started selling drugs and living in the
bathrooms so they had to back down on
that so the fact that Starbucks is now
under assault means the crime is coming
from where crime usually is to places
where it's usually not and that's where
these very liberal woke people don't
want to be disturbed and we talked about
how the Democratic party is changing and
if the Democrats can't get Starbucks
without getting stuck up that is
probably the line that they can't cross
I I totally agree
except I wonder is it just a coincidence
that most of the Starbucks that are
being closed are the Starbucks where
there are moves to unionize because I
that is a fact I mean of the 16
Starbucks clothes
yes
the Starbucks in Union Station is a
dangerous place and Union Station you
see a beautiful place in Washington oh
yeah I haven't been there it's gotten
bad it's pretty bad it's not a state
beautiful building Washington is pretty
bad overall hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else